hey what's up it's giannis pappas and
chris de stefano from the history hyenas
who the hell are you and thank you for
your service your 25 dollar member
you're a non-too holy [ __ ] uh
i'm ivan uh you're a russian kid
what's that now are you a russian kid
the name's ivan
i'm actually puerto rican wow
nice did you do puerto rican day parade
festivities uh this weekend
i did not unfortunately i live in
virginia oh yeah
we've got fire hydrants out there yeah
[Laughter]
he said yeah he said you couldn't
celebrate because you don't have fire
hydrants out there
so you could no not at all yeah you
couldn't play in the water yeah it's
just kidding around
the puerto rican splash what is a puerto
rican doing in virginia how did you get
down there yeah what happened
it's close to puerto rico i'm in the
airport actually i'm kidding oh
thank you for your service holy [ __ ]
thank you so much for your service we
appreciate it service because kim flies
planes thank you for your support
yeah yeah no thank you for your service
because so yeah your 25
amount is actually coming from the
government it's this is government yeah
so
yeah so uh tell us about donald trump
uh you know he's uh he's doing a job
yeah he's not a father he's not a fan
but he's but he but because he's the
president you fight for him you have to
yeah
yeah absolutely yeah no doubt that's why
you got to love these guys these guys
protect us no matter what no matter what
they try to just stay neutral and say
you know what we're in the armed forces
because can you fly a plane are you like
in the air force air force are you still
on the ground most of the time
i'm uh i'm actually an intelligence
analyst holy [ __ ] wow so you [ __ ]
so you've been so you've been looking
through chrissy's porn history you snuck
in
you cracked it yeah yeah actually it's
some pretty sick [ __ ]
how much does he fix it yeah how much
does he spin the wheel with that history
does he push it to the limit there's
actually a lot of tentacle [ __ ]
yeah from what i've seen yeah yeah you
push it to limit
the wheel in my mind when it gets sexual
it starts to get weird i started just i
started to just do things
you know i'm the kind of kid i'll put
chopsticks up my ass in high g be on and
took off
that's what gets me horny is just
thinking about the enemy
yeah um actually no i'm not i don't i
don't do any like sort of like nfa types
i'm actually an imagery analyst so i
work with um
uh you know the drones yeah all right
well we've reached the hate bird
timeline
wait you can't do that to an officer in
the
a little bit neighborhood sorry no
disrespect yeah how are you doing we're
going to we're going to ask him his
favorite we're going to get off politely
because he's
he's he's yeah we're he's a soldier
cousin all right go ahead we can't just
[ __ ] hey burt time limit him hey bert
okay yeah so what's your favorite
episode of the
podcast oh um there's so many of them
but i think the one that stands out to
me is when you were talking about
uh slavery and greece and uh roman
empire and stuff like that
and uh you were talking about how uh uh
chris has like uh you know the the
really good prices for pushing down the
gay and a nice big ass you could stack
uh effect boxes on top of it because
it just it really spoke to me because
i'm built sort of the same way yeah i
get it here's the thing i get it yeah
i love do you know what i love about
ivan right now yeah and what was the guy
before billy
billy you could really see the range in
our fans yeah because look
billy is franks and beans compared to
ivy yeah yeah ivan's like i was like
an intelligence house ivan is an
intelligent he was like i really like
that part where you were explaining
about you know slavery during rome and
it was very educational and then he had
a little fun with you would push down
the gay but i mean billy was like what
what's going on here yeah i don't
[ __ ] walk in there
yeah yeah yeah so we really do got a
range thank you for your service
i really appreciate it and um i
appreciate the call it's made my day
yeah man and please tell everyone in the
armed forces to listen to the history
hygienist because we support the troops
we support the troops yeah
oh i thought you guys up at work all the
time thank you so much all right trump
2020 see you later
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild
[Music]